in that case let's get started all right
thank you for coming to my talk which is
called chasing the Overton window I'm
Alan Downing I work at Driven data I'm a
Staff scientist there if you are not
familiar with us we do data competitions
focused on some important problems in
the world and also data science
Consulting for many mission-driven
organizations
the thing that I'm talking about today
starts with this quote if you are not a
liberal at 25 you have no heart if you
are not a conservative at 35 you have no
brain
curious how many of you have heard some
version of this quote
okay it is sometimes attributed to
Edmund Burke but the reality is we have
no idea could be king Oscar could be
Winston Churchill according to quote
investigator we really don't know except
that it probably goes back to at least
1872 and it appears in several different
languages with different terms that
people would use for parts of the
political Spectrum it's been around for
a while which makes me think that there
might be something to it
so let's find out
I'm going to use data from the General
Social Survey this is a survey of adults
in the United States that started in
1972 and it includes a core of the same
questions that they have been asking for
almost 50 years now so this is a great
resource for tracking how things are
changing over time they have surveyed
almost 70 000 people over the life of
this survey so it's a really rich data
set one thing to be clear about it is
not a longitudinal study that follows
the same people over time it is a
snapshot of a different sample during
each either year or every other year
over the course of the survey
what I found in this data set is what
I'm going to call the Overton Paradox
and there are these four pieces older
people are more likely to consider
themselves conservative
and it is in fact true that older people
hold more conservative views however
people do not become more conservative
with age in fact most Generations have
become more liberal as they got older
nevertheless people think that they are
becoming more conservative that's what
I'm going to try to explain all of the
contradictions among these pieces
along the way I'll talk about some of
the methodology in particular age period
cohort analysis item response Theory
Asian statistics Simpsons Paradox and
you probably see this one coming the
Overton window I'm not going to get into
a ton of depth on any of them but we'll
give you some resources that you can
look at later if you're interested so
let me start with the first one which is
that older people are more likely to
consider themselves conservative and
this is one of the questions in the GSS
is where do you place yourself on this
political Spectrum so as a function of
age this is showing the percentage of
people whose self-identification is
moderate conservative or liberal and it
is in fact true that among the youngest
people in the survey in their 20s they
are more likely to say that they are
liberal and around age 40 or 45 they are
more likely to say that they are
conservative and the crossover point is
in fact between 25 and 35 right where
that quote said it would be so that was
the first result that I saw that I
thought was really striking and
motivated me to explore this more
so as people age they are more likely to
call themselves conservative but now the
question I want to know is do they
actually hold more conservative beliefs
which means that I have to figure out
what are conservative beliefs and I'm
going to do that by taking these two
groups of people the ones who call
themselves conservative or liberal and
find the questions where they differ the
most where those two groups are the most
different which sounds like a really
circular way to Define liberal and
conservative but I think it will make
sense if you bear with me
I started with about 120 questions from
the GSS that were asked over the longest
period of time and I sorted them by the
difference in responses between those
two groups and then I did a little bit
of hand curation to pick questions that
uh covered a variety of topics and that
were asked over the longest interval of
the survey because they're always adding
and removing questions
here are on the left the list of topics
that bubbled out of that process and you
will probably not be surprised by any of
them you probably could have written
this list and then on the horizontal
axis is the percentage of people giving
what I'm characterizing as a
conservative response to the question
and I had to do a little bit of uh
decision there modeling decision about
which ones and where to draw that line
so I got these percentages and you can
see that some of them are really
unpopular questions in One Direction or
the other so for example the top
question is about whether there should
be sex education in the public schools
and almost everybody thinks that there
should be although there is a small
difference about 11 percentage points
between liberals and conservatives and
moderates not surprisingly fall in the
middle at the other end of the range the
difference is about 27 percentage points
which is a big difference but maybe not
quite as big as you might have expected
so I'm going to use the responses from
those questions to characterize each
respondent as liberal or conservative in
terms of their beliefs
one of the problems though is that not
every respondent was asked all 15
questions
as I said the questions were added and
removed from the survey so a particular
respondent might have been interviewed
before or after a question was asked and
each respondent gets a random subset of
the question
however uh most people were asked
somewhere between 5 and 12 of these
questions so I selected the ones who
were at who were asked at least five
because that gives me enough data to
work with
and then I run into the second problem
which is that some of these questions
are more difficult than others in a
sense that I'm going to Define in just a
second so in order to put them onto the
same scale I'm going to use item
response Theory and here is your one
slide introduction to IRT item response
Theory which is that each respondent has
an efficacy which is their tendency in
this case to give conservative responses
to questions and I I could have defined
that scale in either direction but
arbitrarily I said efficacy means your
tendency to give conservative responses
each question also has a difficulty
which is what fraction of people gave
the conservative response to that
question
so those are both unobserved parameters
those are latent parameters but if I
knew both of them if I knew your
efficacy and the difficulty of the
question I could map that onto the
probability that you give the
conservative response to that question
and it's it's the log odds of a
conservative response depends on the
difference between efficacy and
difficulty
in this case I can
get the difficulty of the questions
directly from the average response so
that part is relatively easy but I still
have this inference problem the
inference problem is this
what IRT tells me is that if I know
those parameters I can figure out the
probability of the data great but that's
not what I've got I have the data so I
have to work backwards and infer the
probability of those parameters for each
question and each respondent and
fortunately this is when the spirit of
Thomas Bayes rises from the grave and
reminds us that that is exactly the
problem that Bayesian statistics solves
so again I'm not going to get into the
details of how I did it but what this
allows me to do is for each respondent I
can use the actual responses to the
particular subset of the questions that
they answered to infer this latent
parameter which is their efficacy or
tendency to give conservative responses
and then from that posterior
distribution I generate a predictive
distribution for what they would have
answered to all 15 questions if they had
been asked so that's how I map each
respondent onto a scale of
conservativism measured in terms of
number of conservative responses to 15
questions
so that's the plan
all right so finally answering the
question do older people believe more
conservative things
yes they do
as a function of age from about 20 to
about 90 this shows the estimated
fraction of conservative responses to
the 15 questions for people who
self-identify as conservative moderate
or liberal and the Gray Line there is an
overall average for the group sure
enough older people are more likely to
give conservative responses from an
average of about five and a half or six
up to an average of about eight and a
half so a pretty substantial difference
between the youngest and oldest people
so that is the second part of the
Overton Paradox which is that older
people do in fact hold more conservative
views but part three is people do not
actually become more conservative with
age so here's the first part that might
feel a little bit paradoxical to show
this I'm going to divide people up by
their decade of birth so a Birth Cohort
and then generate that same plot as a
function of age
so again horizontal axis here is age
vertical axis is the estimated number of
conservative responses that dotted line
is the overall average so that's the
same as the line from the previous
figure except now what we have is a
different line for each Birth Cohort
depending on the decade that they were
born so two things you might notice
right away here is that each successive
decade of birth corresponds to a more
liberal set of beliefs starting in the
upper right people born in the 19
oughts and working our way down to the
people who were born in the 1990s each
generation is substantially more liberal
than the generation before
so that's part one part two is if you
follow any particular cohort as they age
in general most of these lines are going
down some of them kind of go up and then
down but the overall trend is generally
downward so not only do people not
become more conservative they actually
become more liberal as they age
this is an example you might have
realized of
Simpsons paradox
so this is a case where the trend within
the groups within the Earth cohorts is
downward toward more liberal but the
overall trend is toward more
conservative if you have not seen this
before and I'm guessing that many people
here are familiar with this but the
first time you see this it seems
paradoxical but it is a very ordinary
thing that data can do
and in this case there's a
straightforward explanation due to the
structure of the GSS data the oldest
people who are seen in this survey tend
to come from earlier generations and
those Generations were more conservative
the youngest people in the survey tend
to come from more recent Generations
which are more liberal so because of
that sampling process we get this
example of Simpson's paradox
all right
the other thing that we learned from
this is that that observation that older
people are more likely to hold
conservative beliefs that is an example
of a cohort effect and not an age effect
so this is the connection here to age
period cohort analysis let me explain
what I mean and age effect is something
that affects almost everyone or most
people at a particular age or a life
stage so for example losing baby teeth
is definitely an age effect if you see a
child who is missing their front teeth
you can make a pretty good guess that
they are about six years old plus or
minus not very much
so that's an example of an edge effect a
period effect is something that affects
most people at a particular point in
time often because of an event or a
period of time like a global pandemic or
like the September 11th attacks those
are things that everybody experiences at
the same point in time not at a
particular age
third category are things that are
cohort effects and these are the things
that affect you because of your life
experience over time the year that you
were born the year that you were raised
when you went to high school all of
those things and it's almost everything
about your idiosyncratic environment
so
often we can look at an effect that uh
that we see in a group of people and try
to infer which of these it is or which
combination of these things it is but in
particular it is common to mistake a
cohort effect for an age effect when we
see that older people are more X it is
tempting to believe that people will get
more like that as they get older and
very often that is not the case for many
different values of x and in particular
the one that we've seen here is people
don't become more conservative with
eight so that's part three of the
Overton Paradox and then part four is
okay but why do they think
that they are getting more conservative
why do they say that they are
conservative when in fact they are
becoming more liberal
and I will tell you my theory about this
which is first that those labels
conservative and liberal are relative
terms they are relative to where people
perceive the center of Mass to be and
that Center of mass has moved over time
and most people over the course of their
lives do not move as fast as the center
of mass does
and so the center of mass is in some
sense overtaking them
so let me show or at least try to show
each of these pieces so the first one is
if these are relative terms
everyone's perception relative to the
center of mass then they shouldn't
change very much over time
the fraction of conservatives liberals
and moderates should be about the same
regardless of how the center of mass
moves
and in fact that is approximately true
so this is now over the life of the
survey going back to about the 1970s to
close to the present this is the
fraction of people who sell for report
that they are moderate conservative or
liberal the moderates have barely
changed in 50 years and they have been
the plurality for the entire duration of
the survey which I think is important to
keep in mind the proportions of
conservatives and liberals have changed
a little bit but I'm going to conjecture
a little bit that part of that is
related to the connotative baggage that
the word liberal acquired during the
Reagan Era which is now gradually
recovering
so I suspect that what changes are there
are mostly because of the popularity of
the term rather than what people believe
so for the most part these things are
relatively stabled a proportion of
people who think that they're in this
these groups doesn't change very much
at the same time what people believed
was changing and it was changing pretty
fast
so this is the spaghetti plot that shows
the responses to all 15 questions over
time and for our purposes right now it
doesn't matter which one is which
overall most of them are going in the
same direction pretty consistently down
which is toward liberal responses over
time
so what this is demonstrating is the
Overton window
which is the range of policies
politically acceptable to the mainstream
population at a given time
so one way to visualize this and I'm
going to borrow this image from the
Wikipedia page that's about the Overton
window is that you could characterize
any given belief at a particular point
in time on a scale somewhere from
Unthinkable to radical to acceptable
sensible popular or in fact things that
are current policy which often implies
that they are
mainstream ideas and what you can see is
that over time there are things that
were Radical in the 1970s that are now
solidly mainstream and things that were
acceptable in the 70s that have left the
Overton window and are now considered
extreme views
so that's a way of thinking about these
changes in terms of the Overton window
things can move in and out of the
Overton window over time
not always in One Direction most of
these were going in One Direction you
might have noticed one exception
I'm going to ask you at the end of the
talk to see if you can guess was it
which of the 15 questions went into
reverse somewhere around 1999.
so we'll come back to this but by and
large these questions have all been
going in One Direction and so if you add
up those 15 you take the average number
of conservative responses over time this
has been going down pretty consistently
meaning toward liberal responses over
the 50 years of the survey
one thing to notice here is that there
is no reversal starting around 2015 or
2016 regardless of what you might have
heard on the topic this is if anything
accelerate
and this is not just
liberals going off the rails Yeah
question the thing is the older
generation has their removed from the
survey
and they were most conservative
rubs their entire life
so as you remove those and you replace
them with young people who are by Nature
more liberal
yes the comment is what's going on here
is primarily generational replacement
which is that as older people who hold
more conservative views die they are
replaced by younger people who hold more
liberal abuse there's actually a mix
there's also the effect of people
changing their minds over the course of
their lives but the majority here is in
fact as you say uh generational
replacement
and all three groups are going in the
same direction so again if you've been
hearing a lot about polarization
polarization can mean a lot of things
but if you take it to mean the
conservatives are becoming more
conservative and Liberals are becoming
more liberal that's not what's happening
in fact all three groups are becoming
more liberal not quite at the same pace
so the slopes of these lines are not
quite the same and so the Gap has grown
a little bit so if bipolarization you
mean that the Gap is a little bit bigger
that is true but it is not huge it has
gone from about 2.5 questions out of 15.
the difference between seven and nine
conservative responses up to about 3.7
so yes that Gap has grown
so Liberals are moving a little bit
faster than conservatives and so we've
gone from 2.5 to 3.7 questions out of
15. although I would suggest that that
is not a qualitative change if we could
have civil discourse in 1974 when we
disagreed about 2.5 questions there's no
reason we can't do that now while we
disagree about 3.7
so that's my comment on can't we all
just get along
I want to do a thought experiment which
is take your time machine back to 1974
and select an average liberal put them
in your time machine and take them to
the year 2000.
they would find themselves very close to
the middle of the road
at that point
so on the left here my average liberal
in 1974 was answering about seven
questions with a conservative response
in about the year 2000 that would make
them a moderate or at least they would
be indistinguishable from a year 2000
moderate and if you bring them all the
way to the present they would be almost
indistinguishable from a 2021
conservative
it
now this thought experiment turns out to
be not entirely hypothetical
let me explain in a second what that
means but again in the year 2000 they
would be moderate in 2021 they would be
right of Center and in fact at that
point they might be more likely to say
that they are right of Center this is
almost exactly what happens to people
who were born in the 1940s
this is the same figure except that the
gray line is no longer a time traveler
that is someone born in 1940.
when they were in their 20s
they were left of center
somewhere around the year 2000 they
found that the world had moved around
them and they were now middle of the
road and now in 2021 they are finding
themselves substantially right of Center
despite the fact that their views did
not change very much over time it went
up a little bit down a little bit and in
fact the net is down
a little bit nevertheless they were
liberal in their youth and they find
themselves right of Center
now in their 70s ish
ended up more liberal than they started
but the world was moving faster than
them and that I think is the key
explanation of the Overton Paradox and
it's not just people who were born in
the 1940s most Generations have had the
same experience this is people who were
born in the 1950s
in their youth they were left of left
by
2005 they were middle of the road and
they now find themselves just a little
bit right of Center
people people who were born in the 1960s
started out
roughly the same as the average liberal
at the time when they entered the survey
you have to be an adult so we first see
people when they're 18 years old so for
people born in the 60s we start to see
them in the 80s at that time they were
about as liberal as the average liberal
sometime around 2010 they hit the middle
of the road and they are now right of
Center on average
people born in the 70s almost the same
story started out about as liberal as
liberal they are now right of Center
however
people born in the 80s said this is now
early Millennials looks like it might be
a different pattern now we don't have as
much data for them so it's a little bit
uncertain but one thing different is
that when they entered the survey as
young adults they were closer to the
middle of the road than any previous
generation
so that's a different start however
their slope is also steeper than any
previous generation they are roughly
parallel to the overall average so they
are moving at the same speed as the
Overton window which is different and
new and for people born in the 1990s
it's possible that they are going even
more quickly than the Overton window
again we don't have as much data and we
only now have seen them I guess in their
20s so it's it is early to say where
that line might be going but clearly
different from previous generations at
least so far so Millennials might be
successfully out running the Overton
window but everybody else is not
and so for them their experience is
going to be what Abe Simpson warned us
all about now I wasn't able to connect
to the sound system so I'll just play
this from my laptop speakers we might be
able to hear it
the end
yeah we got it
if you couldn't quite hear that I'll
I'll repeat it I used to be with it but
then they changed what it was now what
I'm with isn't it and what's it seems
weird and scary to me and it'll happen
to you
and this is true unless your beliefs
change more quickly in over the course
of your life than the Overton window
moves it will happen to you
so to summarize where we are if
conservative and liberal are relative to
a perceived Center and that Center moves
and if most people don't move at the
same Pace it means that one day you will
go to bed thinking that you are with it
and the next day you will wake up on the
wrong side of History
so that is my explanation for the
Overton Paradox it is a combination of
Simpsons Paradox plus this relative
Behavior relative to the Overton window
couple of things I want to tell you
about I'm excited about this in part
because this is a chapter of the book
that I'm currently working on which is
called probably overthinking it this is
going to be chapter 12. this is my first
attempt at a book for a general audience
as opposed to textbooks that I've worked
on before this will be forthcoming from
the University of Chicago press sometime
next year
I will also point out that chapter 2 is
based on the talk that I gave at Pi data
NYC in 2019 so if you want a preview of
chapter 2 you can go back to this very
room
for three years they scheduled me in
this room
I considered wearing the same shirt
I wrote a couple of blog articles there
were some things that didn't make it
into the chapter related to uh
polarization and partisan sorting so if
you want to read more about that it's on
my blog also called probably
overthinking it here are the five ways
that you can get in touch with me if you
want to follow up
foreign
now again
allendowney.com blog will get you these
slides and links to other resources
including the text of the 15 questions
that I talked about again one of them
went into reverse sometime around 1999
and my question for you all is which one
pornography photography is one guess an
abortion guns I hear guns
abortion abortion all good guesses the
answer turns out to be
gun law
if you want to know what's going on
there I have a previous talk
so
I went to scipy in Austin Texas now at
the time I was a professor from
Massachusetts I went to Texas to talk
about gun control versus not the
smartest thing I've done but if you want
to hear more about that that's what that
talk was about
so let me see that is all I have
questions thoughts what can we talk
about
[Applause]
awesome so we have about eight minutes
for questions so there's a lot to unpack
here
um let's see should I just give the
microphone to people or
yeah okay cool let's start here
hi uh it occurred to me watching as you
were showing the cohorts and how they
have different slopes whether
Millennials and gen Z because they are
digital natives quote unquote somehow
social media is
is making them track the Overton window
faster and if there's any way we could
confirm or or disprove that hypothesis
yeah good
so the observation again is that for the
two most recent cohorts roughly speaking
Millennials the slope of those lines is
different from other generations and the
conjecture is that social media might be
the cause
for some reason yes it might I honestly
I don't have an opinion about it other
than yeah I think that's super plausible
but it's really hard to know
so
um there's a lot of perseverating over
how to define uh moderate or political
Center are there in the sort of example
right at the very beginning are there
any moderates that fall outside of the
liberal conservative range if that makes
sense right like or as moderate defined
as being between the the two endpoints
right okay a couple of interesting
questions there and one of them is if we
think of this as a one-dimensional thing
and we think of moderates being in the
middle on a line that is a misleading
picture of what a moderate is if you
picture a highly dimensional space that
has a couple of end points what the
middle looks like is a wildly diverse
group of people so two moderates are not
like each other in the way that if you
know in extreme liberal is giving the
same answer to all 15 questions and same
thing with an extreme conservative
someone in the middle who answers 7 out
of 15 questions
uh there could be you know many many
combinations you can do the
combinatorics and see that there are
many different kinds of moderates there
then the other part of your question is
can you find an individual moderate so I
everything I did was averages Within
These groups but could you find an
individual moderate who is left of the
average liberal or right of the average
conservative I bet the answer is
probably yes as I said there are about
000 respondents and the answer that
people give about whether they consider
themselves to be in one of these groups
is not always consistent with their
answers to the questions
so I haven't looked to see if there are
individuals like that but I would bet
that there are
in fact I suspect there are people who
call themselves conservative who give
very liberal answers and vice versa
with regard to the survey questions
um most of the topics seem to be like
related to social issues I was wondering
if either you consider using like a
fiscal policy foreign policy some other
like categories the social ones
definitely seem to fall in line with
like the idea of those sort of being the
rug pulled out from underneath the
previous generations I was just
wondering if you looked at like you know
some of those other categories
yeah a good observation of the 15
questions that sort of bubbled into my
selection process most of them are
social issues there are only a couple of
economic ones the economic ones are
often questions of the form do you think
we should be spending more or less money
on a particular topic and the two topics
were uh the environment protecting and
defending and to protecting and
improving the environment and Welfare
spending in the GSS there are a bunch of
other questions like that but they are
primarily about public spending so
yes I think you could probably put
together a two-dimensional version of
this where you separated out social
questions and economic questions
it would be interesting to do
all right
when you were imputing the efficacy to
make up for the gapped questions did you
try uh weighting those to take remove
cohort from uh from that amputation does
that make sense so so grouping them with
their Birth Cohort yes okay so the
question is when I was inferring
efficacy which in my case means
conservative responses did I try
grouping people by cohort and so that
way I could see maybe how individuals
within a cohort were changing over time
relative to the center of mass for their
own cohort
uh I didn't do that it's interesting I
think it's a different question I need
to think about it more but it's an
interesting question
so what causes people to Buck the trend
and have you ever studied it what causes
people to Buck the trend so meaning if
the overall trend is toward more liberal
cause someone to become more
conservative over their lives
yeah good question
um outside of my domain of expertise I
have to admit and so you know really I'm
not a social scientist so you should
probably take a lot of this as this is a
data scientist exploring a really
interesting data set and Reporting
things that I found so things like that
are really taking me past the point
where I want to stand up here and
pretend to be an expert on something
that I'm not
um coming back to the Millennials in the
Genesis outpacing the return window code
um how much significantly smaller is the
sample size you in general for this
cohort because smaller samples can you
more extreme results absolutely yeah so
the question is in the most recent
Generations it looks like their slope
might be steeper than in previous
generations but as I said we had less
data here and you're wondering about you
know first of all is this statistically
significant or more generally just how
reliable do we think this is at the
so as an example you see that little
upturn at the end I would not give that
any Credence at all I don't think it
means anything
however we do have a decent amount of
data I think that represents at least
several hundred and maybe about a
thousand people who have been
interviewed so in terms of error due to
random sampling that error is probably
small however many other sources of
potential
you know biases of various kinds one of
the biggest ones the most recent data
set from 2021 the whole data collection
process for the General Social Survey
was disrupted by the coveted pandemic it
used to be an in-person interview now
it's primarily online they changed the
way that some of the questions were
posed and what the available responses
were so that last data point in
particular has a lot of asterisks on it
yes just one more time on those last two
with their interesting Scopes because
see you said on this one that you
wouldn't give much counting to turning
back but the 1980s one one slide before
also shows that flattening pattern
um so the additional slope but also the
flattening just is that also you
wouldn't really comment on that yet or
is it something interesting you think I
those two upticks even though they're
consistent and you're right that is a
little bit of evidence that they might
be legit uh even so again the 2021 data
I'm my general attitude toward that is
we're just going to wait and see what
that next data point looks like
one more question yeah thank you for the
talk I'm in the future as people tend to
give more and more liberal results
assuming that these General Trends
continue
presumably we'll sort of squash squash
into not getting any sort of dynamic
range in the data and you'll just lose
lose the ability to do any inference it
can you sort of start replacing
questions and then you have to do some
sort of clever amputations sort of make
it match up is that kind of feasible or
on the cards uh yes good question so the
observation is that as some of these
questions leave the Overton window we're
starting to get some compression in
particular once you're down into single
digit percentages we can't estimate
those things accurately so if if two
percent of respondents say something
really extreme that might just mean that
they misunderstood the question or any
number of other things that could have
gone wrong now you'll notice several of
these lines don't go all the way to the
right hand side because the GSS does
retire questions at a point where they
feel like they're not learning anything
anymore so in fact not one of my 15 but
one of the other questions that I've
worked with is a question of whether you
think that mixed race marriage should be
legal the number of people who now
believe that it should not be legal is
well into the low single digits and so
they took that off the survey I think in
2010. so that'll happen over time and
now your question is can we still do
some imputation on that it might be
possible if we start to replace
questions to do the same kind of
inference using item response Theory
what I might need to do at that point is
make the difficulty for each question a
function of time rather than a fix
currently it's a fixed difficulty
and but I think if I make it a function
of time that would let me deal with a
rolling set of questions
awesome well let's thank our speaker
again